joining us now is the head elf of chico
california
by the way go chico i'm a cali girl and
i i know where you are
welcome jamie truby hello
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean you're a big deal in this
documentary i i'm
so excited to meet you jamie i'm excited
to meet you too
everyone must watch this documentary it
is i
as you know we've been doing dear drew
uh since the show
launched and i'm a big fan
of snail mail i care deeply about the
united states postal service
and i think the power of a letter is one
of the
acts humans have that is one of the most
powerful things
and how did you apply to be one of
santa's helpers
you know i'm glad you asked that
question from
i am because it's actually not something
you apply for it's something that's
handed down
through the ranks through the
generations i guess you could
say um probably about
five years ago i joined in with
a friend of mine who who was the head
elf at the time and he and i did it for
a number of years
and then as he retired um i kind of took
it over
the main thing you have to know if you
want to be one of santa's elves
you have to learn to read child if you
can't read child you're not going to
make it
so it took some time it took a lot of
time
a lot of sounding out but it's possible
and it it's a challenge my daughter this
is actually from
our personal little vestibule um that we
always decorate each year and this is
her little letter to santa i shouldn't
open it but
um i frankie has already sent her little
letter in
and um i actually have a letter from
ezra who had a very cute request from
santa
may i read please here we go dear santa
if you haven't noticed i've been very
good this year
please send me something thank you ezra
p.s
make the something junk food
yeah yeah you'd be surprised the letters
we get that that's
that's that's a good one well i just
think this documentary
is i felt like i always talk about how
much i love mail
and i just come from those generations
you know i listen
mail has been important since like the
beginning of humanity i mean talk about
romance
people used to have to send letters and
wait for days for a response and now we
live in that world and i'm like get that
snail mail back
um jamie did you ask santa for anything
this year
um you know what i don't ask santa for
for anything um
i'd rather give than receive and um
it it warms my heart it makes me so
happy
to help others
what i did get this year
is i got a new house
two years ago november 8th 2018
the entire town of paradise burned down
where i lived
about 11 000 houses about 700 businesses
we all lost everything it's been a long
two years
um we rebuilt we're back
and things are going great
um and
so what i want this year is is i want to
have the strength
the energy to get through christmas to
get all the children
everything they need everything they
deserve
and come january i've asked santa for
the
energy to continue going on forward
and get my house set up we're we're in
the house we moved in in september
there's nothing on the walls yet but
we're in
we're happy to be here and um
i just i i just i just want a good year
next year
and start setting things up and starting
my life again
i can't think of anyone who deserves it
more and
i'm so glad that things are turning a
corner for you
and you're just such a good person and
you take care of
other people and all the toys and
presents you purchase
from like all these from all these
letters and going to all these kid comes
out of your pockets
you know or the pockets of your
co-workers right
and i just and what you guys are doing
is so incredible and
we want to spread some cheer and we're
going to
make a donation of ten thousand dollars
in your name
to santa's knights a non-profit
organization working with
operation santa to help fulfill his
letters and that's awesome i really want
to get involved in this
also um you know this program is new to
me
and i want you to consider me and
my daughters olive and frankie new
little elves to you
jamie and we'll sidebar and see how i
can get involved to help
your plight of being the magical elf
that you are and
a straight-up rad mortal human who i'm
glad
that good things are coming to you
because i can't think of anyone who
deserves it more happy holidays to you
jamie
dear santa is in select theaters and on
demand now
i demand you watch it because when you
see what people are doing
you will be blown away